hey what's up this doctor john delaney
with ramsey network
today we're going to be talking about
how do you choose to not let things
bother you i got a great email from josh
let's jump into it
josh writes thank you dr d for what
you've been doing brother you're welcome
your wisdom and guidance has helped me
at a time when i've been at one of my
lowest points
man that sucks i'm sorry to hear that
we're thinking about you man and i hope
you're doing well by the time this video
comes out
i still have some work to do but i've
heard you talk a lot about
choosing to not let things bother you
any advice on that
i don't know how to go about just
choosing to not let things get to me
sometimes
thank you for everything josh i love
this question thank you so
much for reaching out here's the deal we
live in a culture that is obsessed with
outsourcing its feelings its thoughts
its actions its responsibilities
everything is always somebody else's
fault
i'm always doing this because she made
me
cuz i have adhd because i was anxious
because i was angry because of something
that happened to me a long time ago it's
just the way our culture works these
days
it's pretty lame we live in a not my
fault society if you want to live a
healthier more productive
more joyful more laughter filled life
with lower stress fewer health problems
not die of a heart attack at 42 less
anger fewer
broken cracked up relationships you can
choose
to not let things bother you or better
yet you can choose to let only a few
things bother you
the few things that matter the few
things that you want to get on a hill
and die
on and the rest of everything else you
can let
roll off as the great jay-z says just
brush your shoulders off right here's a
good example
this weekend my son and i were going
somewhere we were taking my old pickup
truck
i had a big mason jar filled with water
and i set it on top of the cup holder in
the truck
it doesn't fit all the way down so just
resting on top
i'm always talking to my son about how
he smashes through
doors and is always stomping on things
and he just
ping-pongs his way through life he's
like a walking pinball machine right
a giant elephant in a bathroom of sorts
i set this glass of water down my son
gets into the truck he opens the door
slams it jumps in and goes hello
dad and as he did that that water fell
down
dumped the entire jar of water into my
floorboard
and then rolled out of the truck because
i had my door open rolls out of the
truck and smashes
into a bajillion pieces on the driveway
all in one like quick one
second little smash
and instantly i got mad like i felt it
rise up
and then instantly i just exhaled it out
and i looked over at him and said hey
let's get that cleaned up
and i saw him drop his head because he
knows that we're always talking about
entering into a space calmly and with
respect you never know who's on the
other side of a door
i've talked to him about treating my
truck with dignity and not smashing
everything
and slamming doors i also taught him
about saying you're sorry when you hurt
somebody when you break something
and being a part of the solution so he
walked around the truck he helped me
pick up the glass
i looked at him and said we got the
message here and he said yes sir i'm
sorry
i'll be more careful getting in the
truck next time i said cool thanks
so here's the deal my son apologized
he learned a great experiential lesson
it's not just
all theoretical head knowledge he got to
see if he's not thoughtful if he's not
intentional and he's just flying through
life
knocking things over he can dump a jar
of water into somebody's floorboard
smash a glass on a sidewalk all on
accident
all without just thinking right so as a
dad i got my point across
i didn't lose my temper i didn't fly off
the handle i didn't get angry
i didn't give him things to talk about
in some future counseling session right
i chose not to let that bother me he
apologized he helped clean up the mess
he made it right we're moving on so now
we're back to you josh
how do you choose to not let things
bother you
how did i override my instant i'm
frustrated i'm angry
nah i'm gonna move on two words
you decide and you practice you decide
i don't want to be a person who flies
off the handle i don't want to be a
person who walks around life
angry clenched tensed up i don't want to
be a person who's
always looking for where i'm going to
get offended i don't want to be somebody
who's always looking for somebody to
cancel
somebody to permanently ruin over
something they said they got frustrated
they did
accidentally whatever i don't live like
that
i want to live peacefully i want to live
joyfully i want to spend more time
laughing than i do angry i want to spend
more time in relationship
than out of relationship i have to
decide that number one i got to make it
a priority
i got to make it a destination and
number two he's got to practice
i have to practice i've got to come up
with some alternative behaviors and i've
got to implore them
i've got to walk away sometimes i got to
go for a walk sometimes when i'm
exhausted i'm tired
and i'm about to fly off the handle i'll
look at my wife and say i need to go for
a walk from it i'll be back in a second
and she knows me well enough to know
that's my way of saying i love you i
don't want to say something stupid
and so i'm going to head off for a
second i'll be back right and she honors
that
or i'll tell my kids i need to take a
breath for a second
give me one minute i'll be right back
and i'll go in my room
i'll exhale and then i can enter back
into the situation those moments are
rare nowadays
they're rare but they're still there
right they're still there i still have
my default settings
and then i don't want to blow it over
time you practice and you learn to say
things like
ah they don't get a vote ah this isn't
worth hurting a relationship over
ah what am i really getting at here i
want my son to learn how to say i'm
sorry
and to fix his messes that he's uh that
he causes and i want him to quickly be a
part of the solution
when he breaks something that's not his
right i got all three of those things
there's a dad i won
most things aren't worth hurting my
family or causing generational traumas
or flying off the handle so you practice
and you practice and you practice
i've given people close to me permission
to call me out to say hey man you're
being a jerk dude chill out
or what is that about or hey john go
take a walk man
and i listen to him because i trust him
i've given him permission to speak into
my life
it's part of practicing and the more you
practice in short order you will notice
things just start rolling off your back
you'll find yourself not taking big deep
breaths and clenching your fist
you'll see somebody flip you off while
you're driving and you'll just smile
cause okay congratulations dude
i'm going about my day you'll find
yourself get angry and then shut your
shoulders
exhale move on you'll find yourself
going
hey nah you know what i mean
and your whole life will just slowly
slowly start to lift
you decide and practice decide and
practice
it's not some complex google like
what do you call an algorithm right it's
just a decision
i don't want to be like that anymore i'm
going to practice not being like that
anymore
you can control your thoughts and your
actions
and if you control your thoughts and
your actions your feelings your emotions
they'll come alongside
thanks again for the question josh good
luck practicing
good luck deciding you're going to live
a more peaceful joyful life
this is dr john delony with ramsay
solutions don't forget to subscribe
send this video to your buddies if
they're struggling and don't forget
if you want to be a part of the dr john
deloney show if you want to call in and
talk with me
live on the air email me at ask
john ramseysolutions.com leave your cell
number
and kelly or one of the other ramsey
solutions team members will be
in touch with you shortly take care